(ominous music)
(dramatic music)
- [Rick] Here we go!
(dog panting)
- Eh?
- [Reporter] Who are these
unstoppable warriors?
- [Katie] We're the Mitchells,
the only people who can save the world.
- "The Mitchells vs. the Machines"
is an animated movie about a teenage girl
who is leaving for college
for the first time,
and her family, who's
trying to hold onto her,
in the midst of a robot apocalypse
that threatens the world.
(laser zapping)
- Get down!
- Hi, my name is Mike Rianda.
I'm the co-writer and director
of "The Mitchells vs. the Machines."
This is a scene in the
beginning of the movie,
and this is right after Rick and Katie
had this big argument that
leads to their big falling out.
Katie's excited to leave for
college and never look back,
and Rick sorta looks at the past
and how warm and sweet it was,
and he's desperately
trying to get that back.
(ethereal music)
(objects clunking)
This scene was in the script.
We were talking about trying to have
a visual symbol of their relationship,
and we were trying to sorta
figure out how to make it
more visual and tangible,
and then I remember,
Jeff threw this kinda dusty
moose on a whiteboard.
Right here is this dusty moose you drew.
And then we thought that
was such a great symbol,
because she hasn't thought about it,
and she even throws it away.
And we were like, "Oh my
God, it'd be so brutal,
if you found something
that you gave to your kid
that meant a lot to you,
that they just threw away
when they left for college, so."
It was a way to try to
feel closer to Rick.
We wanted the audience
to want what he wanted,
which is like, "I've gotta
save this relationship."
We really wanted the scene to look
like it was a real teenage girl's room,
which is a disaster. (laughs)
For her to have all of these strange,
sort of idiosyncratic things,
from like weird B movie
posters that she loves,
these little puppets that she makes.
A part of this character is
just having her creativity
sort of exploding out of
the frame in every moment.
(melancholy music)
(Katie sighs)
It was a real challenge
to get the hood on her.
It's so funny, in 3D animation,
the weirdest things
are hard and expensive.
And they were like, "You
got one hoodie shot.
Make it count," (laughs)
and we were like, "What?"
Two of the hardest things to do in 3D
are hair and cloth simulation.
When cloth is interacting with hair,
aw, it's a bonanza of money! (laughs)
So we tried to choose
our hoodie shot well,
and this is an area where
we really wanted her
to feel bad and down,
so we chose this for the one moment.
(melancholy music)
- Why is he like this?
(water hissing)
- Why is she like this?
- Jeff wrote the lines,
"Why is he like this,"
"Why is she like this," which
nicely sort of connected
the characters through editing.
It was also, in that shot,
really important for her
to be looking at a
picture of her and her dad
when they got along well,
but you also wanna show the audience
that she too once valued
this relationship,
and she subtly would like it to return
to the way it used to be.
It was really important
for the audience to know,
she does want a relationship with her dad.
(water hissing)
- Did you talk to her yet?
- [Rick] (clears throat) No, not yet.
- The performances in an
animated film are a handshake
between the voice actors
and the animators.
The voice actors come first,
and then the animators
animate to the voice track.
And this scene is filled
with great performances.
The animators' whole job
is making the characters
act like real people.
Linda's, she's nervous,
and she doesn't wanna
confront her husband,
but she also feels like
she needs to say something,
so she's like rubbing her
hand and avoiding eye contact.
Rick is washing dishes.
There's a nice little finger tap there.
One of the animators added that.
It was so exciting because it meant
the movie was a little bit more alive,
and some artist was bringing
something new to it.
These are digital puppets! (laughs)
They're not human beings.
So any tool you can
use to try to make them
seem more real is like money in the bank.
But seeing the animator
add something like that,
it makes me so happy.
- You just broke her laptop!
I mean, look, we haven't
had a good family picture
in years because you
two are always arguing!
- Huh, well, what about that one?
- That came with the frame!
- This picture, we had in a screening,
and we loved this picture
and it made everyone laugh,
and then we couldn't get the rights to it.
And then I hired this guy called The Wolf,
and he was able to track them down,
and we got them to sign a
release and we were able
to use it in the movie!
- I know you can do this.
- This is the first shot
we locked in the movie.
And one of our artists, I
think it was Toby Wilson,
did this amazing color key that looked
exactly like we wanted
the whole movie to look.
And then we worked with Mike Lasker
and his amazing team at Imageworks,
and Mike came from "Spider-Verse,"
so he knew the pipeline of 3D animation
to match a painting exactly.
So this is the first shot
that we did for the movie,
and I'm super proud of it.
(melancholy music)
This scene is really dark.
It really sort of makes you
feel how devastated Rick is.
We did this color key
and the entire studio
revolted against it, saying,
"This is too dark!" (laughs)
It has to be this dark
because Rick is in a bad place
emotionally and you have
to really feel that,
and also, when you watch
TV at night, it's dark.
And I think it really does help the scene.
(Katie and Rick laughing)
A lot of the reasons why
these shots are exteriors
is because Rick kind
of romanticizes nature.
And the relationship he
had with his daughter
was that she did
everything he liked to do.
So he liked to go into nature,
so she's going with him,
And so when he looks at the past,
he sees all those moments and he's like,
"That's what we need to get back."
But what he really needs to
get back is sort of, you know,
seeing his daughter and
seeing who she's become,
and the movies that she makes,
and the person that she is now.
(Katie and Rick laughing)
We wanted this scene to be entirely
from Rick's point of view.
This is his whole motive,
is to get back to these
days and seeing them
kind of through rose-colored
glasses a little bit.
The shots are really overexposed,
'cause we were trying to get that feeling
of what home movies really look like,
and they often have bad lighting. (laughs)
- Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba!
(Katie giggling)
- I love that piece of acting.
That was pitched by Alan Hawkins,
who has a kid of his own,
and it's just like, (imitates munching)
but it's something I'd never
seen in an animated movie.
It's something you would
never think to animate,
but all of the team brought
so many new ideas like this to the film,
and I think in the
storyboards, they just hugged.
- And now, the Mitchell
Family Talent Show!
♪ Mi-a-ha ha ♪
♪ Mi-a-hee ♪
♪ Mi-a-hah ♪
- We literally added this
scene of them singing
to justify this act three payoff we had
with them singing together
at the end of the movie,
to try to make it feel cohesive.
♪ Mi-a-huu ♪
♪ Mi-a-ha ha ♪
(explosions booming)
(Rick chuckling)
(sentimental music)
- Bye, Katie! Are you excited for camp?
- [Mike] This is the part
where you see that Rick
is actually a really good dad.
- Oh, hey-
- This is one of the most
important scenes in the movie,
and it took so long to tweak
the dialogue to be just right
and have Rick sort of give her this totem,
this thing that's really important to him,
but also, he's being a goofball.
Him trying to sort of do anything he could
to cheer his daughter up
and get her to stop crying
and get her to feel happy and confident
about leaving for camp instead of scared.
- You know how to say "I
love you" in moose language?
Let me just, ooh!
(Katie giggling)
Don't you laugh, come on,
you're supposed to be sad!
Hey, come on!
(music fades)
- I love that shot of him sadly
looking at his reflection.
(melancholy music)
(Rick sighs)
- Alright, let's fix it.
- And he stands up and
he says, "Let's fix it."
That's the action that basically inspires
the rest of the movie.
I'm really proud of this scene.
I've read so many people say,
"I'm 14 minutes in and I'm
already crying," and every time,
I'm like, "Oh, it's this
scene, this is the scene!"
I check, 14 minutes in,
and I think it's really
a credit to the team,
sort of everyone firing on all cylinders.
I think every single person
who touched it made better.
It's easy for me to say,
because I'm just proud
of all the things that the
other artists did. (laughs)
They did all the good stuff,
and I just sort of was a
enthusiastic cheerleader for it.
(gentle inspiring music)